WHEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATE RIGHT
PRESIDENT. BRADFORD PRESENT
SENATOR CHIANG PRESENT. THANK%
PRESENT SENATOR CAFIERO PRESENT
AVEIRO PRESENT SENATOR
DOLLINGER. SENATOR DORADO.
THEY'RE ALSO PRESENT SENATOR
HUESO. HUESO PRESENT SENATOR
PORTANTINO YOUR SENATOR
PORTANTINO PRESENT YOU HAVE A
QUORUM MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED WE'RE GONNA LAY
DOWN THE GROUND RULES FOR THIS
HEARING TODAY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BANKING FINANCE
WILL KNOCK ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
IN RESPONSE TO COLD AT NINETEEN
URGENCY. TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF MUST
NOT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
IT HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
COMPLY WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE WILL HOLDING A CENTURY
NINE. IN HAS MADE SIR IT JUST
NEEDS TO KNOW PRICE IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. ARE CONDUCTING HEARING
IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC
AND OUR EMPLOYEES TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE A MINUTE.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
BE USING TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
IS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANTS TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT HERE RIGHT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPATE. NUMBER
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE
THREE SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE.
THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE
THREE SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE AN
ACCESS CODE IS FIVE NINE ZERO.
FOUR THREE FIVE FIVE ZERO FOUR
THREE FIVE. WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THE MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THE TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. NOTE
THAT I ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID. ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET YOUR
DEVICE YOU ARE USING ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY ON YOUR
PHONE. IT IS THAT WE HEAR FROM.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN THE
CHROME DURING THE HEARING AS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. DOCTOR
RICHTER FOR HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINING HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND AS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNERS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO USE THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENCE SO
WE'RE SO ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
CAN BE HEARD. TODAY WE HAVE TWO
BILLS TO BE HEARD HERE AND
SENATE BANKING. FIRST UP IS SB
NINE OO EIGHT BY SENATOR Y.
KASKI N. NOW THERE IS SB
FOURTEEN THIS FORTY SEVEN BY
MYSELF BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS BILLS WE'VE ARE
AS- LONG. AND OTHER IF OUR
PURSE AUTHOR RATE CENTER Y. QUE
YOU MADE. SB NINE AWAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES FIRST OFF I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THAT AMENDMENTS
CONTAINED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
I'M GRATEFUL FOR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE WORK THAT THEY
PUT INTO THIS BILL AND GETTING
IT IN THE SHAPE IT'S IN TODAY.
SO WHAT THIS THING THE
CALIFORNIA. LICENSE THAT
COLLECTS. DEBT BUYING INDUSTRY
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS HAD LAWS ON
THE BOOKS REQUIRING FAIR DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVENS. ARE
LAWS TO LITTLE TO STEM THE BAD
BEHAVIOR- WHICH THIRD DESIGNED
TO PROHIBIT. THIS IS BECAUSE
THE LAW REQUIRES THE CONSUMER
TO SUIT THE DEBT COLLECTION.
COMPANY THE CONSUMER HAS A
RIGHT TO SUE THE DEBT
COLLECTION COMPANY BUT MOST
CONSUMERS. HAVE THE MEANS TO BE
THE ROCKS AND THE LOS. EVEN FOR
THE FEW WHO COULD AFFORD AN
ATTORNEY IT IS FINANCIALLY
WORTH THE TIME. TO TAKE THAT TO
BRING A LAWSUIT AGAINST A
COLLECTION AGENCY WHO VIOLATED
THEIR CONSUMER RIGHTS BY
COLLECTING AGAINST THE WRONG
PERSON ATTEMPTING TO COLLECT A
DEBT ALREADY PAID OR INFLATING
THE AMOUNT THAT MONEY OF MONEY
OWED OR MISREPRESENTING
THEMSELVES. SO CONSUMERS AT THE
END OF THE DAY NEVER BOTHER TO
SUE AND THEY JUST GIVE UP. SO
SB NINE AWAIT WOULD ADD
CALIFORNIA TO THE LIST OF
THIRTY FOUR STATES ACROSS OUR
NATION THAT REQUIRE A LICENSE
IN ORDER TO COLLECT I CONSUMER
DEBT. WITH THAT- YOUR SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIR I DO BELIEVE THERE
ARE SUPPORTERS. IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU. OKAY DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH SO HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN NEW CLING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE A TIME LIMIT ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES ALL OTHERS
WITNESS TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAMES
AFFILIATION AND POSITIONS ON
THE MATTER MEASURES WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ANYONE INTERESTED IN
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM- TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF SPEED NINE AWAIT.
SEEN IN HEARING NINE. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY.
STANDING ROOM ONLY SEEN NINE.
MOVING ON NOW THANK YOU WELL
NOW WITH THE AGO TO WITNESSES
WANT WANT WANT TO TESTIFY
VI<c.cyan> TELLER CONFERENCE MISTER</c>
MODERATOR PLEASE PROPPED
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
ON SB NINE AWAIT. BIN LADEN
GENTLEMAN- COULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. LOOKS LIKE AS OF
NOW- WE DO HAVE ABOUT- SIX THAT
ARE IN HOLD. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER MODERATOR- WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN LINE WILL TAKE THE
FIRST CALLER SUPPORTING CON SB
NINE AWAIT. ABSOLUTELY SO THE
FIRST ONE WE GO TO ANNOUNCE
THEM BY NUMBER WE GO TO NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE THESE. I DISAGREE
VARYING DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION
AND COMBINE IT WITH THE PUBLIC
LAWCENTER IN ORANGE COUNTY. AND
WE STRONGLY UPPORT AT THE NINE
OH EIGHT AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE GO TO
NUMBER SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVEN SIX PLEASE MAKE
SURE NOT MUTED. NEXT CALLER BUT-
FIVE FIVE YOUR OPEN. REMEMBER
IN THE MARKET- CONSUMER REPORTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE ON AT A TIME OF
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY OVERSIGHT
IN THE INDUSTRY A CRUCIAL WE
RESPECT THE REQUEST NINE THOSE.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE
GO TO NUMBER SEVENTY ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALL. NEXT WE GO TO
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS JEFF BY THE LOWER
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF ONE ADDITIONALLY I'D LIKE TO
THE NOTE THAT I RECOGNIZE YOU
DON'T HAVE A LITTLE MICROPHONE
COVER. AT THE OTHER CHECK
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN PREVIOUS
HEARING AND I'M AND I'M JUST
LIKE TO POINT THAT OUT AND I
FEEL LIKE ALL THE OTHERS THERE
SHOULD. BE A LOT OF THE SAME
COVERAGE OF THE MICROPHONE
THANK YOU. I THINK IT'S A
CONSPIRACY HERE. NEXT CALLER.
NEXT TO YOUR NEW NUMBER SIXTY
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME SHARED CAN
MODEL THAT. THANK AT THE EAST
BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE EIGHT
AND CARE ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO
GO TO NUMBER SIXTY NINE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLUE
CLIFF BURGUNDY AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS WEARY SOMEONE IN IT
THE TWEENER WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH SENATOR WORK HOUSE HE AND
HIS STAFF IN BEHALF OF
INDUSTRY- WE FEEL WE MADE
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS WE HAVE A
FEW MORE ISSUES OUTSTANDING-
WHEN WE RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES WE
WILL BE IN A POSITION TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. AS OF TODAY
OUR POSITION HOWEVER IS SUPPORT
IT AS AMENDED WE WANT TO
CLARIFY GROUNDS FOR REVOCATION
OF THE LICENSE VIOLATIONS OF
THE ROSENTHAL ACT CANNOT BE FOR
TECHNICAL REASONS AND A COUPLE
OTHER ISSUES CAP ON IT YOU'LL
SEE. AN ESTABLISHMENT OF
ADVISORY BOARD THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE PROGRESSING
AND THAT. IT WILL AGREEMENT
BEFORE THE BILL MOVED. IF NOT
BEFORE THANK YOU. MISTER
MODERATOR THERE ANY OTHER CALLS
IN Q. WE HAVE- TWO MORE IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU NEXT CALL. NEXT
WE GO TO NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR KAREN MEMBERS
TO CIVILIAN TRITON ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE
LENDING AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. IN
LASSEN MOVING TO AT THE MOMENT-
WE GO TO NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT PEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS- DAVID READ ON BEHALF
OF THE RECEIVABLES MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION INTERNATIONAL- WE
ARE A TWEENER- ARMY EYES
OFFICIAL POSITION IN SUPPORT IF
AMENDED. WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE ON SOME
FINAL MOMENTS AND WE EXPECT TO
BEING IN A SUPPORTING THE SHINS
VERY. THANK YOU. MODERATORS
THAT CONCLUDE OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT VIA TELECONFERENCE. YES
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NOW WILL
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
CAN YOU Q. THOSE- ALL WHAT WE
FIRST HAVE. BRUCE HERE IN
COMMITTEE ROOM FORTY TWO ALL
THREE PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME IN
YOUR POSITION. CALIFORNIA OUR
ASSOCIATION A STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION OF LAWYERS WHO-
PREDOMINATELY DO DEBT
COLLECTION- WORK ON BEHALF OF
CLIENTS FIRST- AND WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AND WE
ARE ASKING FOR A NARROW
EXEMPTION FROM THAT- BUILT. I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY NOTING THAT
LAWYER. COLLECT DEBT ROUTINELY
SOMETIMES IT'S CONSUMER DEBT
COVERED BY THIS BILL SOMETIMES
THEY'LL BE ENGAGED TO COLLECT
CHILD SUPPORT DELINQUENT CHILD
SUPPORT OBLIGATIONS SOMETIMES
IT'S A JUDGMENT THAT REMAINS
UNPAID AND I'LL BE ENGAGED TO
COLLECT ON THAT DEBT.
COLLECTION OF DEBT BY LAWYER IS
AN INTEGRAL PART OF LAW
PRACTICE. NOW LAST YEAR SENATOR
WE CASKEY HAD SB ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN WHICH WE DIDN'T POSE
WHICH CLARIFY THAT. ALTHOUGH
LAW FIRMS HAD ALREADY BEEN
SUBJECT TO THE ROSENTHAL FAIR
DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICES ACT I
WAS TOLD THAT THIS NARROWLY-
CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE AND MADE
SURE THAT IT WAS CLEAR THAT
LAWYERS ARE ALSO SUBJECT. TO
THE ROSENTHAL FAIR DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES ACT AND I
WAS TOLD THAT IS NOT A STRETCH
BECAUSE THE STATE ARE ACT ALL
READY REQUIRES LAWYERS TO
COMPLY WITH THE ROE AND FALL
DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICES THAT.
TIME WOULD HAVE. OF BUT SEVEN
SO POINT BUT I WILL SAY IN YOUR
WELCOME TO LOOK AT A IT IS A
FULL OF THING THAT WE SHALL DO
AND SHE NOT TO IN COLLECTION OF
DEATH BUT THE LAST SENTENCE IS
A WILLFUL THIS SECTION
CONSTITUTES BECAUSE FOR THE
IMPOSITION OF DISCIPLINE OF THE
ATTORNEY IN ACCORDANCE WITH
SECTION SIX OH SEVEN SEVEN IN
OTHER WORDS THE STATE BAR HAS
FULL AUTHORITY TO DISCIPLINE
LAWYERS FOR VIOLATIONS OF THE
DEBT COLLECTION LAWS. THIS IN A
SITUATION WHERE THE STATE BAR.
WORK REGULATE SMOKERS EXCEPT
FOR SOME LOOPHOLE THAT EXISTS
THE STATE BAR REGULATES LAWYERS
FULLY UNDER THIS SECTION FOR
DEBT COLLECTION LAWS SO ALL I
WOULD SAY IT WE'VE HAD CORDIAL
AND PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
SENATOR WE CASKEY BUT EVERYONE
IS HURTING NOW AND LAW FIRMS
ARE HURTING LIKE EVERYONE ELSE.
AND SO WE'RE JUST TO HAVING A
SECOND LICENSE FOR MAY SECOND
REGULATOR. REGULATE EXACTLY THE
SAME ACTIVITY THAT OUR S
ALREADY BEING REGULATED BY THE
STATE BAR THIS IS DUPLICATIVE
AND THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO
SUBJECT LAW FIRMS OR ANYONE
ELSE IN MY VIEW. TO DUPLICATE
OF UNNECESSARY EGULATION WHEN
THEY'RE ALREADY COVERED BY THE
STATE BAR SO WITH THAT WE WOULD
ASK FOR A NO VOTE IN LAST
APPROPRIATE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THIS IS
SHERIN SENATORS CLIFF COSTS
ONLY HALF THE UNITED TRUSTEES
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE
AND THEIR STAFF- AND WE
APPRECIATE IT KNOWLEDGE MEN OF
THE EXEMPTION FOR FORECLOSURE
TRUSTEES STILL WORKING ON THE
LANGUAGE A LITTLE BIT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FINISHING THAT
MOVING OUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU I SEE NO
FURTHER WITNESSES AND ROOM
FORTY TWO OLD THREE LET'S MOVE
TO RUN TWENTY FORTY. ANY
WITNESS IN A TWENTY THE SCENE
NINE. I WILL NOW TURN TO OUR
MODERATOR AND. THIRTY NI
CALLERS IN Q. THAT ARE WILLING
TO WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION MR MODERATE. JOHN ON
THE PHONE LINE SECURE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE MANAGER
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. LOOKS LIKE AT THIS TIME
WE DO HAVE TWO THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THE FIRST LINE WILL
GO TO HIS NUMBER EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY TWO THIRTY I HAD. YEAH
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ACTUALLY I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT MY NAME IS DANIELLE
KENDO KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION. WE THINK THE AUTHOR
AND THE URGE YOUR- THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. NEXT
THEN WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FIFTY
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MELANIE GRANT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
I WANTED TO KNOW THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE WE HAD
WITH THE AUTHOR AS WELL THE
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENT. I'M UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT AN
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM. FOR MEMBER BRING AND
THE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ALSO
NOTED IN THE EXEMPTION
SOMETHING UNFORTUNATELY AT THAT
TIME WE START MADE UP. LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
DIALOGUE THE- THREE. YOU NEED A
DISH WITH ON LINING KEY. AND
OPPOSITION MISTER MINER. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE OKAY HEARING SEEN
NINE I'M GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE BUT BEFORE I DO
SO I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
BETWEEN THE LAST HEARING IN
THIS HEARING ALL THE COVERINGS
ON THE MICROPHONES HAVE BEEN
AND SO THOSE. EXPERT NOW THE
CURRENT ROOM MICROPHONE PHONES.
WERE CHANGED BETWEEN PARENT SO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. MAN
OF ICE YEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE CENTER Y. CASKEY FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD ON
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE ONCEPT I
KNOW FROM SPEAKING TO MAKE
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT CHALLENGES
THAT THEY FACE WITH DEBT
COLLECTION BUT I'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE ASKING QUESTIONS OF.
THE OPPOSITION WE HEARD MR
BELOW WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
CREDITORS SO FISHING THAT THERE
ISN'T JUSTIFICATION FOR
INCLUDING LAWYERS WERE ALREADY
LICENSE IN THIS BILL SO WHAT
THE COMPELLING REASON LOTS STIR
OF WHAT IS GOING TO INCLUDE
ATTORNEYS IN THIS PROPOSAL.
FOLLOW AT SEVEN TWO FIRST THE
PRACTICE OF LAW IS NOT TO
PRACTICE OF DEBT COLLECTION AND
I THINK THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE TO
LICENSE SINCE WHAT STATE ARE.
LOOK LICENSES AND REGULATES
ATTORNEYS IN THE PRACTICE OF
LAW IT IS NOT PRACTICE. IS NOT
THE PRACTICE A DEBT COLLECTION
THAT ACTIVITY OF DEBT
COLLECTION IN- IS DIFFERENT
POSSESSING LEGAL TRAINING MIGHT
BE ADVANTAGEOUS TO THE BUSINESS
OF THAT I THINK BUT IT'S NOT
THE SAME ACTIVITY. TO THAT END
LEGAL THANK WOULD BE AFFECT.
SEVEN WHICH IS OF. INDUSTRIES
YOU CAN. AND A ARCHITECTURE HE
AID TO SPEND. BUT ALL. THERE'S
LICENSE THEY HAVE CAJUN THAT
BUSINESS THE STATE UP HAS
PROPERLY THIS. BARK THIS THESE
OF THESE LICENSES YOU CAN. BE
UP. INTO THE GROUP. ACTIVE
SHE'S. BEEN TO. BUT AND SAY I
GET A PER EXAM SO WOULD BE THE
YOU KNOW HERE'S MY PASS MY PER
PASSED SOME OF IT I DON'T NEED
TO PET GROOMING LICENSE SO
THAT'S THE FIRST ONE EVEN IF
THE EXTENSION EIGHT FOR THE
PROFESSION ATTORNEYS ON FIRM
PARTICULARLY. UNDESERVING OF
THE LOOPHOLE AND LET ME IT WAS
A BANKRUPTCY ATTORNEY WHO WAS
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE DEBT
COLLECTORS IN A LAW FIRM
OPERATE TODAY COLLECTOR DEBT AS
MILLS THEY SEND THOUSANDS OF
LETTERS TO PEOPLE ON THE WALL
LET HEAD AND THINK CASE THE
CONCERT USING LAW FIRM'S NAME
THERE'S A IN THAT THEY DO THIS
MADAM VICE CHAIR SITS AFFECTED.
IS CONCERNED TO KNOW LAW FIRM
AND THEY PLEDGING THAT THEY OWN
A TAD AND INTIMIDATED. THEY'RE
FRIGHTENED. AND THE BIG THEIR-
AND SAM IN WHAT HEAD AND THEY
START MAKING. AND REITERATING
SEND THE IT'S IN THE- I'M NOW.
NINE AWAIT IS USING HIS USES
THE EXISTING CIVIL CODE THE TO
DETERMINE WHAT A DEBT COLLECTOR
IS THE BILL APPLIES ONLY TO THE
PERSON WHO IN THE ORDINARY
COURSE OF BUSINESS REGULARLY ON
A PERSON'S OWN BEHALF FOR ON
BEHALF OF OTHERS ENGAGE ISN'T
THAT COLLECTION. THIS IS NOT
DIDN'T THE- ATTORNEY WHO'S
GOING AFTER DEBT ONE OF THEIR
CLIENTS WHO HASN'T PAID THEIR
BILL OR IS IT IS A DOING THIS
ONE OFF THEIR SEEKING TO GET
PAID- THEIR YOU KNOW THEIR OWN
SERVICES THIS IS THIRD. THEIR
PRACTICES. NO I'M A LAWYER- I.
OPPOSE THE IDEA OF EXEMPTING
LAWYERS FROM LICENSORS. I THINK
THAT I'M GONNA LOSE MUCH OF MY
SUPPORT FROM ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU HEARD OF AN INTERN
COLLUDED IN THE- STATE THIRTIES
ANALYSIS. THAT LEGAL SERVICE
LAWYERS NO BETTER THAN ANYBODY-
THE SERIOUS PROBLEM IN THIS
SPACE OF DECK COLLECTING- IN
SOME OF THOSE SUPPORT LETTERS
THEY CAME AND WORKED SO WE'RE
SAYING. EVEN WITH THE STE
FEDERAL CONSUMER PROTECTION.
AGENCY A MOUNTAIN MMHM. MOST OF
THE- COMPLAINTS COME IN OUR UP
THAT COLLECTING AND PEOPLE
DON'T EVEN OVER THE DEAD.
GETTING IN WRITING SO THIS IS
AN OTHER PROTECTED. MAYBE IT
LOOKS LIKE THE INCONVENIENCE
FOR THE LAWYERS IN THIS SPACE
BUT- REALLY NECESSARY FOR THE
CONCERT. IT CAN ITHANK YOU SO
MUCH CAN I CAN I HAVE MISTER
BELOW ALSO ANSWER- TO INSTALL
IF I MIGHT MISTER. SIR WE
COUNTIES EFFECTIVE ORDER BUT
RESPECTFULLY HIS ANALOGY
DOESN'T STAND. HE WOULD SAY
THAT IF YOU REPRESENT A
CONTRACTOR- THAT'S FINE THIS IS
TANTAMOUNT TO REQUIRING A
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE IF YOU
REPRESENT A CONTRACT. THE
CALIFORNIA CREDITORS BAR
REPRESENTS CLIENTS WHO EITHER-
HAVE EXTENDED CREDIT AND
WEREN'T PAID. FOR WERE- BUT
DEBT AND ARE THE LEGAL OWNER OF
THE DEBT SO THEY ARE
REPRESENTING A CLIENT EXACTLY
AS A LAWYER REPRESENTING. THE
CONTRACTOR IN HIS CASE OR A
LAWYER REPRESENTING THE
VETERINARIAN THEY ARE A CLIENT
OF THE LAW FOR. AND SO THIS IS
A TROLL TO THE PRACTICE OF LAW
AND THERE ISN'T ANY. SPEAKING
CENTER WORK SUGGEST THERE BEING
SOMETHING WITH THE ROSENTHAL
FAIR DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICES
ACT SPEAKS TO COLLECTING DEBT.
AND THE STATE BAR ACCESS THAT
YOU CAN LOSE YOUR LICENSE IF
YOU VIOLATE THE ROSENTHAL FAIR
DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICES ACT
IN OTHER WORDS YOU CAN BE
DISBARRED. FOR FAILING TO
COMPLY WITH ROSENTHAL AND SO
THIS IS SIMPLY A DUPLICATE
LICENSING SCHEME OF FOR THE
SAME ACTIVITY. THE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE MEETING ENTERS
THE QUESTION FROM START AT NO
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. OF
FOR RESPONSE SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY. I SUPPORT THE BILL OVERALL
BUT I REALLY DO REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE TESTING TO
WIDE OF THE NET OVER THE
COLLECTION MARKET- AS MENTIONED
TO ATTORNEYS ARE LICENSED UNDER
THE STATE PARTNER ARE TO MEET
STANDARDS UNDER THAT LIKE IT'S
AN AYE VOTE LOOK I VOTED FOR
SB. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN DOES YOUR
BILL LAST YEAR THE- WELL. DEBT
COLLECTION PARK ACT AND- AND
ATTORNEYS ARE REGULATED UNDER.
YOUR BILL LAST YEAR BUT I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
BE MORE PRESCRIPTIVE WITH OUR
REGULATIONS SO THERE ARE NO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES- GIVEN
THAT. I AM GOING TO LAY OFF
TODAY AND I HOPE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THIS ISSUE TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE I. PUT IT ON THE
PHONE I'M REALLY HOPING THAT WE
CAN WORK ON IT BECAUSE- YOU ARE
RIGHT YOU KNOW DEBT COLLECTION
SHOULD HAVE OVERSIGHT
CALIFORNIANS. DESERVE A
CONSUMER PROTECTION IN THE
SPACE SO THANK YOU BRING THE
BEFORE. THANK YOU CENTER GLORIA.
WELL I WON'T I WON'T BELABOR
THE POINT BUT I FEEL PRETTY
MUCH THE SAME WAY IT I
UNDERSTAND YOUR POSITION TO ME
JUST SAY THAT I LIKE THE BILL I
THINK THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
WE NEED TO- REGULATE A DEBT
COLLECTION. BUT BUT IN IN THE
DISTANCE OF ATTORNEYS IN
PARTICULAR- THEY- SENDING OUT A
LETTER CAN BE INTIMIDATING AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT IT'S ALSO
WITH. THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE OF
WHAT APPROPRIATE IN TERMS OF.
OF DEBT COLLECTION IF YOU SAID
THAT THEY WERE USING. PRACTICES
THAT- IS THAT I'VE I'VE HEARD.
ARE USED THEN I MIGHT FEEL A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY ABOUT IT
BUT I JUST DON'T SEE ANY NEED
FOR A- SECOND REGULATORY
ORGANIZATION. THE FACT THAT YOU
CAN LOSE YOUR LICENSE I TO BE.
I TO BE- SCARY ENOUGH AND
FRANKLY. IF THE STATE BAR IS IN
DOING THEIR JOB THEN I THINK WE
OUGHT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE
STATE BAR AND I THINK WE DO
NEED SOMETHING ABOUT THE STATE
BAR BUT UP BUT NOT IN THIS BILL
SO I WILL SUPPORT A BUT I. TO
CONSIDER AN AMENDMENT THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD TAKE ATTORNEYS
OUT OF THAT BECAUSE I DO THINK
THERE WAITED ON PROCRIT LATE-
UNDER PRIOR BILLS AND THE STATE
BAR. ANY THIS QUESTION FOR
MEMBERS SHE NINE CENTER Y.
COSCO TALKED RESPONSE YEAH I
BIRDS I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE C. AC AND BARI ARE M. A. R.
THIRD LISTED IN THE- BUT THEY
ARE NOT CONTINUE TO THEM RIGHT
NOW I'M JUST NOT IN A POSITION
TO GIVE THEM EVERYTHING THEY-
BECAUSE OF. THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAVE IN THE SPACE AND ALSO
QUITE FRANKLY GIVEN THE
PANDEMIC THAT WE HAVE THE
INCREASED- DEBT THE PEOPLE ARE
TAKING ON RIGHT NOW AND THE-
THE POTENTIAL FOR JEFF IN IN IN
THIS ARENA SO I WOULD CHEN FIVE
FIVE. INTO THE MEASURE GOING
AND I CONSENT. CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU. I'LL TAKE
THAT AS A CLOSE- MEMBERS WERE
SEEKING A MOTION ON SB NINE OO
EIGHT. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DORADO WE HAVE A TO
PASS AS A MINUTE TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL NINE AWAIT THE
MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
BRADFORD HI. UNDER CHIANG.
SENATOR CABALLERO I. SENATOR
DOLLINGER. SENATOR RUSSELL.
SEND REQUESTS SO I'VE SENATOR
PORTANTINO MINUTE BOAT RIDE
TODAY BUT OBVIOUSLY WANT YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
GROUPS AND WE'LL TALK ONCE
AGAIN MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES
DON'T. MEASURES FIVE ZERO
MEASURES OUT NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM. NUMBER TWO.
AND THAT WILL BE S. B. ONE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN I WILL TURN THE
GAVEL OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
MADAM VICE CHAIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR SO BUT WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR SENATOR
BRADFORD TO BEGIN I JUST WANT
TO REMIND ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AN ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE
THREE SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. FIVE
NINE ZERO FOUR THREE FIVE FIVE
SO MISTER CHAIR WE'RE READY
WHEN YOU ARE. THANK YOU MA'AM
VICE CHAIR. SB. ONE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN IS A DIRECT RESPONSE TO
THE ECONOMIC. DEVASTATION AS
BEING CALLS MICHAEL IN NINETEEN
THE MEASURE PROVIDES PROTECTION
AGAINST FOR CLOSURE FOR MOM AND
POP LANDLORDS. IT ALSO CLOSES
LOOPS IN TWO DIFFERENT LAWS
THAT ARE INTENDED TO PROTECT
HOMEOWNERS FROM. OF FRAUDSTERS
WHO CHARGE TO HELP PEOPLE AVOID
FORECLOSURE. SB FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN FOCUSES ON KEEPING ROOFS
OVER PEOPLE'S HEADS BY BUILDING
ON LEGISLATION THAT WAS ENACTED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND TWO
THOUSAND NINE. FOUR FORECLOSURE
CRISIS AND THE HOMEOWNERS BILL
RIGHTS CLEARLY WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO A GREAT DEAL MORE
WORK BUT I HOPE THAT THIS
MEASURE CAN PROVIDE SOME.
SACRAMENTO RELIEF FOR
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE STRUGGLING
IN WHO ARE JUST FOR TO KEEP
THEIR HOMES TODAY WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THREE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AN MARTIN
DAY. UNIONS I A MER SEVERAL
TORRES FROM THE CENTER ON
RESPONSIBLE LENDING AND I GOT
JOE HER AMERICA MEAL FROM THE
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS-
THE STILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. GREAT SO WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ANYONE WANTED TO TEST
FIND SUPPORT IN AND THE CHIU
MISTER SURE YOU'VE IDENTIFIED
THE THREE PRIMARY WITNESSES I
WILL CALL ON THOSE INDIVIDUALS
FIRST. SO ONCE THOSE WITNESSES
HAVE TESTIFIED- CALL FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SO LET'S PROCEED WITH YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES. ARE THE HERE
ALL OF THEM ARE AND YOU WILL
HEAR ME. YES YES. RIGHT THANK
YOU WANTED TO CONFIRM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CARE AND MEMBERS ARE
YOU THEN MARTIN DEL WITH
CONSUMER REPORTS FORMALLY KNOWN
CONSUMERS UNION- I WILL ALSO
SPEAK FOR MY COLLEAGUE MARK
ABOUT FOR THE R. L. SHE HAD-
PERSONAL MATTER ON PERSONAL
EMERGENCY AD IS NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFIED TODAY OVERALL ONE
THANK I THINK SHARE OR BRING
THE MEASURE FORWARD- IT IS A.
THANK FOR BOND HAYLER. BADGER
THAT WOULD EIGHT FROM LOOPHOLE
IN REALLY. LAWS THAT WE PASS
THE LAW BY NOW CRISIS THAT WERE.
TO IT. SURE THAT WE CAN STOP ON
THAT THE FORECLOSURES
DISPLACEMENT OF HOMEOWNERS THE
PAN AND WE LEARNED A LOT IN THE
LAST DECADE YOU HAVE LEARNED
THAT THE HOMEOWNER BILL OF
RIGHTS WHICH WE ALL WORKED.
HARD TO PASS UP. I'VE BEEN.
DURING THE SOMEONE FROM GOING
TO REPAIR THEM. THERE ARE CLEAR
CA STAND REQUIREMENTS PUT ON
LOAN. TO ENSURE THAT YOU CAN
FOR OTHER WALK GEISHA OPTION.
INCLUDING THE MONICA CAN FOR
CHRISTINA FORECLOSURE GIVEN THE
UNPRECEDENTED NATURE OF THE
CURRENT CRISIS HOW MANY
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HAVE LOST
THEIR JOBS OVERNIGHT. MANY HAVE
CANNOT PAY THE RENT- BUT OF
COURSE FOR ONLY THE MULTI
FAMILY PROPERTIES- THERE IN A
BIND BECAUSE THE CAR THE BILL
OF RIGHTS HAVE NOT QUITE A
THEM. DATE THE BILL WAS VERY
CORDIAL X. AND. AND SANDERS THE
OWNER OF THE MULTI FAMILY. THE
THEY CAN WORK SOMETHING OUT
WITH THEIR FOR A THIRD.
UNNECESSARY WHICH CAN LEAD TO
THE- OF HANNAH. WHAT KIND OF
HAVE RIGHT WE'LL CALL YOU THE
PROPER MATTER WE A LOT RIGHT
HOW CAN LOCAL PROPERTY THE VERY
FALL. POSITION AND HOME.
ANOTHER PIECE OF THE MEASURE IF
YOU CLOSE A LOOPHOLE. IN THE
ALARM HAPPILY TO MORE DIFFICULT
CONSULTANT. WERE THIRD PARTY
PROVIDERS. CASES TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO
RETAIN OUR MORTGAGES
UNFORTUNATELY MANY LICENSED
ATTORNEY YOU GOT INTO THIS
BUSINESS. AND THE PEOPLE IN
FRONT OF ALL RIGHT DEFINED AND
I'M TALKING ABOUT YOU FOR
SERVICE. DID NOT HELP PEOPLE
WERE VERY IMPORTANT LEAD. OF
WHAT YOU CAN SHOW THAT FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT. YET MAYBE
IT. WOULD. ARGUED ABOUT THE FOR
SERVICE AND- THAT MAY NOT PAN
OUT AND INSURE THAT THE STATE
BAR CAN OF COURSE- STATION
THOSE- THOSE ACTORS ON THE
BOTTOM. OF THE BAR WHO MAKE
YOUNG. THINKING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF AN UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION FELT REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT MEASURE WE
THINK IT'S ONE OF MANY PIECES
OF LEGISLATION. PASSED YEAR TO
ENSURE THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AS PART OF OUR
RESPONSE THE CALL THEY CRIED
CRISIS. THE REALLY APPRECIATE
LEADERSHIP. MAKING OUT FOR
WORKING ON THE- REQUEST NINE
THE. THANK MS MARTIN MARTIN. A
DOUBLE CHECK IS. MARCIN BUILT.
SHE'S NOT SHE'S NOT HELP JOEL
ME. ARE YOU. ON THE LINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AB MEMBERS MISTER
CHAIR IN MADAM VICE CHAIR JONES
I MEAN- FROM HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC RIGHTS ADVOCATES JUST
WANT TO CONFIRM THAT YOU CAN
HEAR ME. YES. HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC TWENTY EIGHT TRIED TO
ADVOCATES ARE HERE FOR SHORT.
SUPPORTS SB FOUR FOUR SEVEN
BECAUSE IT WILL HELP PROTECT
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS IN DANGER
OF LOSING THEIR FAMILY HOME
WHERE THEY'RE SMALL RENTAL
PROPERTY. MUCH NEEDED
AMENDMENTS TO THE HOMEOWNERS
BUT OUR RIGHTS IN THE
FORECLOSURE CONSULTANT LAW
PARTICULARLY. GIVEN THE
CURRENT. EMERGENCY. THE
NONPROFIT WE SERVICE ANY
ORGANIZATION LOCATE IN OAK THAT
CA. STATE WITH THERE ARE. IN
DEALING WITH THAT IN CREDIT
PROPER. INCLUDING FORECLOSURE
PREVENTION AND- WE SUPPORT SB
ONE FOUR FOUR SEVEN EXTENSION
OF THE HOMEOWNER BILL OF RIGHTS
PROTECTION TO TEN IN OCCUPIED
PROPERTIES. NO MORE. THAT
HOMEOWNERS DESPITE OLDER DOOR
FREAK HAVE ONE OR MORE RENTER
IN THE DEPEND THAT RENT INCOME
TO MAKE ENDS MEET AS MANY
RESIDENTS INCOMES HAVE
DISAPPEARED IN THE FACE OF THE
PANDEMIC RING DANGER OF SEEING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LOT TO
FORECLOSURE IN OUR STATE ON
MASS INCLUDING SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES DUPLEXES TRI PLEX THEN
FOR THIS. THING BECAUSE
APPARENT FOR PROTECTIONS FOR
HOMEOWNERS IN SMALL PROPERTY
OWNERS TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME RENTERS IS OURS FOR
THEMSELVES. ONE FOUR SEVEN WILL
AND H. NEEDED. AND HELP PROTECT
VULNERABLE. FROM LOSE THEIR
HOME WHEN THEY CAN CAN AFFORD
TO PAY THE RENT. ON A VIRUS
RELATED LAW HAVE BEEN C<c.cyan>.</c>
THERE ARE SUPPORTS AS ONE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN. AMENDMENT TO THE
FORECLOSURE CONSULTANT LINE SO
THAT IT CAN REALLY ACTIONS
TAKEN TO POSTPONE DELINQUENCY
WHEN THE CRISIS PREGNANCY
HOMEOWNERS ABILITY TO PAY THEIR
MORTGAGES SUCH APPEARANCE THIS.
HAIR AND WE'VE SEEN A
RESURGENCE OF FORECLOSURE
RESCUE SIXTEEN OUNCE OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS. VERY HARD
MANY. CREDIT EQUITIES AGREE. IN
THE MORE COMMON DEMAND OF AN
UPFRONT PAYMENT IN EXCHANGE FOR
A PROMISE TO SAY THE HOME
THROUGH NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
WINDOWS BUT OFTEN DOES NOT COME
THROUGH. THIS IS TRAGIC BECAUSE
FREE ASSISTANCE IS AVAILABLE TO
HOMEOWNERS FROM HOUSING
COUNSELOR IS THE SENATE SIDE BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT. NON
PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS I CARE NOW
THAT LENDERS ARE I BRING FOR
PARENTS- TO HELP PEOPLE DURING
THE CRISIS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ADD THIS TO THE LIST OF ACTIONS
COVERED BY A FORECLOSURE
CONSULTANT WANT. RIGHT AT HOME
SO. HAVING TO. AND NECESSARILY
THAT SIR. SAM AND I STRONGLY.
AS BEING ONE FOUR FOUR SEVEN AM
COMMAND CENTER BRAD FOOD IN AND
IN THE SENATE FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND WE REQUESTED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO CONTINUE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THIS ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
HE TURNED SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN. SEEING
NONE- THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR WRIST
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IF THERE ARE ANY. IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN. PLEASE IN GERMAN ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE END OF YOUR
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE TWO
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT. OKAY
PLEASE CEDARS WE GO TO THE LINE
OF- NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ASH MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE PLAN
TROUT AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
AND COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THEN THE LAST ONE WE HAVE IN Q.
WILL GO TO NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AND- HI
A I YES I'M NOT QUITE SURE IF
THIS ON THE BALLOT HARVESTING
IS THAT CORRECT NO THIS IS A-
BANKING. THIS IS BANKING
COMMITTEE. ALL I'M I'M SORRY I
GOT AN EMAIL TO CALL IN ABOUT
THE BALLOT HARVESTING AND- SO I
CAME IN LATE TODAY CAN I SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT NO. THIS IS
A DIFFERENT EIGHTY EIGHT. YES
THEY ALREADY HAPPENED I THINK
YOU CAN SUBMIT AN EMAIL. YES
OKAY CAN I GET HOW YOU I KNOW
SO MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE GETTING
MULTIPLE FORMS FOR THE CENSUS.
YEAH SO I I'M SORRY IF YOU CAN
EMAIL YOUR ABOVE MAYBE THERE'S
THE SENATE RULES AND THEN WE
CAN PASS IT. ALONG THANK YOU.
SENATE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE IF
YOU CAN PASS ALONG YOUR EMAIL A
SEND YOUR EMAIL TO SEND
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE THAT BE
GREAT. A MISTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO BE SURE WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES.
FOR SB FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN FOR
BANKING COMMITTEE. AND AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE. GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH-
HAVING HER FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELEPHONE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN WE WILL BEGIN. AND
ON THE PHONE LINES IF YOU'RE
NOT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NOBODY IN THE QUEUE HEY CAN YOU
PLEASE CHECK LINE ONCE AGAIN TO
BE SURE THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
ALL THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
ABSOLUTELY ONCE AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME- WE
HAVE NOBODY IN THE QUEUE THANK
YOU SO MUCH SO WE WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBERS TO ANY OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SIR HUESO. I JUST
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE THIS IS A
THIS IS A GREAT BILL. THIS IS A
VERY CREATIVE BILL. VERY WELL
THOUGHT OUT I THINK IT'LL GO A
LONG WAY TO HELP. HOMEOWNERS
KEEP THEIR HOMES IN A WAY THAT
YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAN ASKING HOW
DO WE KEEP PEOPLE. IN THEIR
HOMES WITHOUT THEM LOSING AND
IF THEY- HAVE TROUBLE MAKING
THE PAYMENTS ARE IN THIS
CRISIS. IT'S VERY NICE AND ON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
HAVE A SOLUTION LIKE THIS I
WANT TO COMMEND. OF EVERYONE ON
THE AUTHORED STAFF FOR WORKING
ON THIS- GREAT SOLUTION AND
I'D- LOVE TO BE AS IT HAS TO.
PASS A CO AUTHOR TO THIS BILL
ON THE LIKE TO MOVE AT THE
RIGHT TIME. THANK YOU IN.
CENTER DRAWS. YES I ALSO A
SUPPORT AND COMMEND THE AUTHOR.
IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE A THEY'RE
VERY FEW WAYS FOR WORKING
FAMILIES TO BUILD- WEALTH IN
EQUITY. THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO WORKING
FAMILIES EVEN AFTER MUCH
SACRIFICE. BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY YOU CAN SAY I OWN
SOMETHING. AND SO- YOUR
PROTECTIONS FOR THEM WHEN
THINGS ARE REALLY HARD AND
REALLY TOUGH. I THINK IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR THAT
REASON STILL I ALSO SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS. I'D ALSO- I JUST
WANTED TO ALSO ADD OF MY
SENTIMENTS AS WELL I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL AND I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS A
CO AUTHOR AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME- SO THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER WAY SO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE SENATE
FLOOR SECRETARY PLEASE. SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN DO
PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
BRADFORD. CHIANG HI. ZERO HI
BALLY. TO RANSOM. HUESO ALL
RIGHT PORTANTINO. MEASURES
SEVEN VOTES ITSELF. THE BILL IS
SAYS SEVEN FIVE ZERO KNOWS. AND
WITH THAT I'M GONNA TURN IT
BACK TO MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIRMAN THANK THE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR PARTICIPATION
TODAY- WHO PARTICIPATE IN IT
AND OUR WITNESSES WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THIS TESTIMONY.
IF YOU WERE IT NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE BANKING AND
FINANCE INSTITUTIONS COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL. HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU FOR YOU THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR THEIR PATIENCE IN
CORPORATION THIS CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
STANDS ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.